[Music]
on this thursday night a victory for
carbon pricing in canada's highest court
the supreme court ruling on putting a
price on pollution
what it means and the reaction i think
it's unfortunate it's an ineffective
policy
multiple states of emergency in the
southern u.s tonight as dangerous
tornadoes touch
down and an update on that ship wedged
in the suez canal
is it any closer to getting unstuck and
exceptional exhibit i think we're very
blessed to have
a center like this the world's largest
any wheat art museum
opens in winnipeg
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
we begin with a significant ruling from
the supreme court of canada
in a six to three decision it is ruled
the federal government has the power
to set a minimum price on carbon a big
victory for the trudeau government
the top court says climate change is
real and this matter is critical to our
response to an existential threat
to human life in canada and around the
world the majority of judges ruled
no one province territory or country can
address the issue of climate change on
its own
it makes it clear carbon pricing is not
a tax but a regulatory
mechanism to induce behavioral changes
that will lead to widespread reductions
in emissions
and it ruled any province's failure to
act threatens canada's ability to meet
its international obligations which
in turn hinders canada's ability to push
for international action
to reduce greenhouse gas emissions
therefore a provincial failure to act
directly threatens canada as a whole it
was conservative premiers in three
provinces alberta
ontario and saskatchewan who challenged
the liberal carbon pricing plan
today they lost the supreme court
decision does not change
our core conviction that the federal
carbon tax is bad environmental policy
it's bad economic policy and it just
simply is wrong
this may end the legal challenges but
not the political battles
eric sorenson has our top story tonight
it was never as simple as a fight
between federal liberals and provincial
conservatives
it was a debate over the historic
division of constitutional powers
between ottawa and the provinces
it came down to the harm from climate
change what the court deemed as a threat
of the highest order
to the country and ottawa's response a
national carbon tax
in a landmark ruling from the supreme
court six of the nine justices declared
that climate change is real
chief justice wagner wrote for the
majority the harmful effects of
greenhouse gases are by their very
nature
not confined by borders adding
parliament has the jurisdiction
to enact this law as a matter of
national concern
under the peace order and good
government clause of the constitution
this is an historic day for canada
and for our planet for the economy and
for all canadians
for generations to come the supreme
court heard challenges from three
provinces
alberta saskatchewan and ontario that
the law infringes on provincial
jurisdiction
alberta's premier quoted a dissenting
justice that the decision turns
provincial autonomy on its head
in jason kenney's view the west is being
treated unfairly
and no we're not going to back down on
defending our jobs our economy
and uh and our powers under the
federation
but he did accept reality obviously it's
a majority decision of the supreme court
uh there's no court
that we can appeal this to is it time to
move on ontario's premier an opponent of
the tax did not speak out today
and the canadian chamber of commerce
welcomed the certainty
the decision it says provides important
clarity that businesses require to make
investments
it's key for these provinces to to move
forward with a strong climate plan to
make sure that they're really
positioning their provinces to be
competitive
in a decarbonizing global economy for
the liberals it is a clear road ahead
its plan will boost the price on carbon
this year to forty dollars a ton and it
will rise to one hundred seventy dollars
a ton by twenty thirty
real financial costs to canadians for
burning fossil fuels that are being
offset
with rebates from ottawa still the
federal conservatives say they will
scrap the carbon tax
and replace it with a better plan still
to be announced
conservatives will focus relentlessly on
recovering from the recession
creating jobs and we will have a plan to
reduce emissions
this is a moment for the conservatives
to use the opportunity
of the court case to say we fought as
hard as we could
they've been given an exit door by the
supreme court's decision
they all need to take it the supreme
court has settled the question over
ottawa's power to legislate on climate
change
but with a federal election coming the
political fight over climate policies
is not over yet eric sorensen global
news toronto
there was a big shift on carbon pricing
in the american oil and gas industry
today
the american petroleum institute a trade
group that represents 600 companies
including chevron and exxon mobil
has endorsed putting a price on carbon
it signals the industry which is a huge
greenhouse gas emitter would prefer a
quantifiable cost associated with
climate policy
rather than changing government
regulations president biden is preparing
to unveil a sweeping infrastructure
proposal
focused on curbing greenhouse gas
emissions and transitioning to clean
energy
now to the threat from kobit 19
according to the federal government more
than 10 percent of canadians
have now been given at least one dose of
a covet-19 vaccine
that works out to more than 3.8 million
people
the federal government says it expects a
steady flow of vaccine deliveries in the
weeks ahead
but the virus is spreading faster than
the vaccines are rolling out
driven by those more contagious new
variants and that is leading to rising
case counts
and stark warnings we are in a
precarious position
daily cases are increasing and
hospitalizations are increasing and icu
numbers are increasing
in terms of active cases per capita
alberta is hardest hit right now it has
148 cases per 100 000 people
that's followed by saskatchewan bc and
then ontario
and a growing number of cases in those
provinces are
the new variants ontario reported more
than 2 000
new cases today the first time since
january the number has been that high
the province's top covet advisors
believe new variants now account for
about
55 percent of new cases there to get
canadians protected as fast as possible
officials are urging people
to accept whichever vaccine they are
offered there has been confusion
and concern over the oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
including a small number of reports in
europe of extremely rare blood clots
there have not been any reports of blood
clots in this country
though health canada has added a warning
about the potential side effect
as heather urex west reports the agency
still firmly believes the shot is safe
and effective lindsay molech has been
vaccinated against covid19
i have and it was astrazeneca and i
don't feel at all worried about it
the toronto woman has listened to the
seemingly endless amount of news around
this particular vaccine
information that seems to be updated by
the day yesterday in an effort
to provide canadians with the most
complete and up-to-date information
possible
health canada announced that it has
updated the product label for the
astrazeneca and kobe shield vaccines
the new warning label comes after a
small number of patients experienced
serious blood clots within two weeks of
receiving the astrazeneca vaccine
in canada the provinces have
administered over 300 000 doses
of the kobe shield version of the
astrazeneca vaccine
and we have not received any domestic
reports of these rare events
the country's top doctors maintain the
vaccine is
safe and effective but this infectious
disease specialist
knows many canadians are now feeling
confused
i think so we're already seeing a lot of
that so people are asking so many
questions about astrazeneca vaccine
and how can inconsistent information
with poor communication not affect
people's
take on the vaccine despite the new
warning dr constantinescu says
real-world data has shown this is a good
vaccine
in a new analysis of its major u.s trial
data
astrazeneca now says its vaccine is 76
effective against symptomatic covid19
and 100
effective against hospitalization the
reason i had took the vaccine was i want
to
stay out of the hospital and i don't
want to die which is why when given the
opportunity
lindsay mullick says the astrazeneca
vaccine was good enough
for her heather urex west global news
calgary
there is trouble ahead for kovacs the
global initiative to get kovid 19
vaccines to countries in need
organizers have confirmed they will be
affected by india's decision
to pause all major exports of
astrazeneca vaccine produced there so it
can focus
on its domestic needs organizers say
they've been told deliveries from the
serum institute of india will be delayed
in march and april
the sierra institute is a key player in
the initiative to help dozens of
lower-income countries
inoculate their populations the federal
auditor general had some good news and
some bad news today about some of the
most expensive programs the federal
government
has ever put together the a.g gave high
marks to the government on the rollout
of the covid relief programs
though as david aiken reports she also
found canada was not prepared
for the pandemic auditor general karen
hogan handed out
rare high praise to the government for
its signature pandemic relief programs
the
canada emergency response benefit and
the canada emergency wage subsidy
they prioritized the speed of getting
support
to individuals and businesses
and then made adjustments in real time
but hogan was
sharply critical of the trudeau
government's so-called investing in
canada plan
that's the multi-year 188 billion dollar
plan launched in 2016
to underwrite new infrastructure hogan
said the plan is a mess
money is not flowing fast enough and
reporting is inconsistent
the absence of clear and complete
reporting on the investing in canada
plan
makes it difficult for parliamentarians
and canadians
to know whether progress is being made
against the intended objectives
hogan also wrapped the public health
agency of canada
for failing to fix problems first
identified
more than 20 years ago the agency
had not planned for
nor prepared for a nationwide quarantine
the health minister said that will be
fixed every country as
i said is going to be reviewing lessons
learned and there will be a full
review of the public health agency of
canada
the auditor general also found that the
government did a haphazard job in the
first few months of the pandemic
tracking inbound international travelers
thought to be a high risk of violating
quarantine orders
i want to acknowledge that the
consistent application of these new
border measures across
across all ports of entry can be
improved
finally hogan looked ahead saying her
office has plenty of work to do on
pandemic related audits including
tracking the government's performance on
vaccine distribution and procurement
look for that
vaccine verdict this fall david aiken
global news
ottawa residents in new brunswick are
hoping more answers will come soon about
a mysterious cluster of cases of people
with a neurological
disorder 43 cases have now been
identified five people have died
the disease appears to be concentrated
in the acadian peninsula and the moncton
region
it affects all age groups and its origin
is unknown
health officials are investigating and
public anxiety
is growing so people who
think that they have that disease right
now they think they have
they all pass through the emotion that
no cure
and the end is dead i'm not sure this is
the right answer
they should need right now so please
help those people
as fast as possible new brunswick's top
doctor says no stone would be left
unturned in a collaborative
investigation that includes neurological
experts
and various government agencies the
high-profile investigation into sexual
misconduct allegations against canada's
top general
took another turn today canada's
military watchdog rejected the defense
minister's claims about what powers his
office had
to look into the complaint the
contradiction came to light in testimony
before a house of commons committee
investigating the matter
and as our ottawa bureau chief mercedes
stephenson reports it is raising
questions about the best way to protect
victims
who come forward reporting structure of
the ombudsman
canada's military watchdog delivered
powerful testimony on parliament hill
that defense minister harjit sajin was
the right person
to hear allegations of sexual misconduct
against
canada's former top general this is a
critical point that needs to be made in
order to correct the record
had i been faced with the same facts i
would have done
exactly as my predecessor did military
ombudsmen gregory lick
pointed out sajin was the only person
his predecessor gary walborne
could have brought the allegations to
under the circumstances
the current reporting structure of the
ombudsman is directly to the minister of
national defense
not to the privy council office or any
other body the testimony is a direct
public contradiction of minister sajin's
claims that it would have been
inappropriate for him to hear the
concerns or receive evidence
i'm sorry no politician should ever be
directing
investigation getting involved in
investigation that's absolutely wrong
the senior military police officer who
commands the canadian forces
national investigation service the
military police unit
currently handling allegations against
two consecutive chiefs of the defense
staff
also appeared to cast doubt on the
defense minister and
prime minister's assertions that sajin
accepting evidence of misconduct
or taking that to the police would have
constituted political interference
asking me to examine and look at would
not be interference
interference would be improper conduct
during the investigation as it relates
to the cfnis
the testimony comes one day after sajin
intervened
asking the chief of the defense staff
general wayne ayer
to review a navy investigation into
alleged sexual misconduct
which concluded without interviewing all
complainants or witnesses
on wednesday afternoon the cds announced
he was ending
operation honor the military's mission
to stamp out sexual misconduct
saying operation honor has culminated
and thus we will close it out
harvest what has worked learn from what
hasn't and developed
a deliberate plan to go forward the
decision came
after many victims have said they felt
op honor was
ineffective and poisoned with op honor
now over
the question is what comes next and as
for the defense
minister his office says he has always
reported any allegations
to the appropriate authorities donna all
right mercedes in ottawa thanks
the southern u.s on high alert coming up
the warnings about dangerous weather on
the way
meanwhile in canada the fair evading
commuter who
shut down a subway station
oh my god in there it's right here
there are reports of fatalities in
alabama tonight and reports of several
tornadoes touching down a state of
emergency
is in effect in dozens of counties as a
severe weather system generating
tornadoes blows through
it has snapped trees destroyed homes and
downed power lines
the national weather service has issued
a rare tornado emergency
and it is calling the situation
particularly dangerous
the man accused of killing 10 people in
a colorado grocery store made his first
court appearance today
the judge ordered the 21 year old be
held without bail
he faces 10 charges of first degree
murder and one count of attempted murder
the district attorney said more charges
are likely
investigators are still working at the
crime scene police say the man opened
fire with an assault style weapon
and among those killed was a police
officer and father of seven who
responded to the call
the accused did not enter a plea today
his lawyer says she needs more time to
assess his mental health
if convicted he faces life in prison
without parole
in washington president biden held his
first formal news conference since
taking office
and he ducked a question on gun control
he did say
north korea is the biggest foreign
policy threat facing the u.s
right now that country has a gain
test-fired ballistic missiles
it's believed they were two short-range
missiles that flew about 450 kilometers
before landing in the sea of japan biden
says the u.s is consulting with allies
and will respond if things escalate
experts say north korea is looking to
expand its military capabilities
and ramp up pressure on the biden
administration to restart nuclear talks
former president trump abandoned those
negotiations
in 2018. the ever given
won't give still ahead the struggle to
clear the giant ship
clogging a key trade route
you're watching global national
[Music]
tugboats dredgers and that little
backhoe have failed to free that huge
container ship stuck in the suez canal
teams of experts from japan and the
netherlands have now arrived to assess
the situation
it's described as like a heavy whale
that has beached
it's blocking traffic in both directions
and it may take weeks to free the vessel
causing a new setback for global trade
it means that the flow of goods is not
going to be as rapid
as before until the canal is clear
roughly 30 percent of the world's
shipping container volume moves through
the suez canal every day at least 150
vessels are now waiting to pass through
the canal well road signs are a critical
component
keeping traffic flowing and it generally
helps to spell the signs correctly
the person who painted this one near
rome could have used
spell check the letters are all there
just in the wrong order
the mayor posted this picture and it
wasn't long before order was restored
and stop
was properly spelled next a first for
the world a look inside a new gallery
showcasing an unrivaled collection
there is now one place in the world to
see the largest public collection of
inuit art
and it's right in the heart of canada
the winnipeg art gallery has just opened
kaumayuk
a stunning new gallery that adds nearly
40 000 square feet to the existing
building in downtown winnipeg
a place to educate and inspire visitors
showcasing
14 000 pieces of inuit artwork
its inaugural exhibition opens today
with a virtual event
and tonight global's marnie blunt gives
us a peek inside
[Music]
it's moments like this that give maureen
gruben inspiration for her artwork
my inspiration mostly comes from my
environment that i grew up with
here in the arctic on the
shores of the beaufort sea collecting
bones and fur
working with ice and other raw materials
gather near her home community of
tuktoyaktuk
gruben often blends the nature of the
arctic with industrial materials
my work is inspired by this land
the ice many of her pieces ingrained
with a powerful message
preserving the arctic ice speaking for
the polar bears
or helping the environment by
highlighting the impact of climate
change
they just come through me i just feel
like i'm the conduit and
these words just come through me she's
one of nearly 90 artists featured at
kaumayuk
the new inuit arts center at the
winnipeg art gallery the 40 000 square
foot facility
bridges canada's north and south
showcasing inuit art and providing a
place for research
we've exhibited and published more than
any museum in the world
but we've never been able to to kind of
share more than probably one percent of
the collection at any time
gruben's piece waiting for the shaman
consists of polar bear bone paws
and is part of inuwa the center's
inaugural exhibit
i think we're very blessed to have a
center like this where we can showcase
our work and celebrate
our ancestral talents it was one of my
dreams to be
having one of my work shown in the old
winnipeg art gallery this
so i've been working toward this goal
this stream for about 25 years
labrador artist shirley morehouse has
two pieces at inuwa
both have deep-rooted messages of
preserving memories
and the environment i'm blessed to have
it make it aesthetically beautiful but i
always try to have a conversation
somehow
and now kamlyuk provides a global
platform for those conversations
marty blunt global news winnipeg
and that is global national for this
thursday i'm donna friesen
tonight's year canada is about as
canadian as it gets this eager beaver
was spotted early this morning in a
toronto subway station
no idea of its destination or whether it
paid the nickel fare that's a special
rate for bieber's
animal services were called and the
beaver was safely escorted back
into the wild thanks for watching take
care of yourselves
[Music]
[Applause]
bye-bye
you